et on débute cette matinale avec la
rencontre hier à moscou entre vladimir
poutine et emmanuel macron plus de cinq
heures de discussions pour désamorcer la
crise russo occidentale sur l'ukraine à
l'issue il admire poutine s'est montré
rassurant emmanuel macron lui a évoqué
des termes de convergence avec la russie
pour plus de précisions on va tout de
suite retrouvé notre correspondant à
moscou antoine éclaire ouf
[Musique]
bonjour en toi alors vous étiez sur
place à hyères vous avez suivi
l'intégralité de la conférence de presse
alors que retenir de cette rencontre
entre vladimir poutine emmanuel macron
hier
olivier bien rappelez-vous le président
français était venu à moscou avec un
objectif à l'esprit le vrai pour une
désescalade dans cette crise ukrainienne
et deux dirigeants ont livré leur vision
leur interprétation des événements et
sans surprise les différences sont
importantes le président russe a par
exemple remis en cause le caractère
pacifique de l'alliance atlantique en
citant les interventions à belgrade en
libye ou encore en afghanistan et en ce
qui concerne la russie vladimir poutine
fait voilà fait valoir que moscou ne
menace pas les frontières ukrainienne et
dénonce le refus occidental de mettre
fin à l'élargissement de l'otan écoutez
nous ne pouvons pas
passer outre
la
définition stratégique donné par l'otan
en 2019 dans laquelle l'otan est désigné
comme menace et comme adversaire
et dans cette infrastructure militaire
qui se rapprochent de leurs frontières
elle se considère concerts qu'elle a le
droit de nous donner des leçons de nous
dire où placer nos troupes ou faire des
manoeuvres et c est encore une fois je
dis que
aujourd'hui
il y à cette présence qui est considéré
aujourd'hui comme une menace pour le
cred mais il ya d'autres pays les pays
baltes d'autres pays voisins sur quelle
base ils abritent des troupes de l'otan
je ne sais pas c'est pas mais enfin tout
cela fait que ça une politique assez
étrange vis-à-vis de la russie et les
pays continuent les autres pays que les
occidentaux continuent à augmenter la
puissance militaire de l'ukraine a
participé à sa formation à sa
modernisation et en envoyant des
instructeurs des spécialistes
emmanuel macron de son côté à une
lecture différente des événements et dit
vouloir prendre compte du point de vue
de chacun y compris les pays qui se
sentent menacés par la russie comme
l'ukraine les pays baltes ou encore la
pologne et ce pour trouver des points de
convergence afin de bâtir je cite des
garanties de sécurité écoutez moi la
priorité si je peux être très clair avec
vous c'est la stabilité de la situation
sur le plan militaire à court terme
sur cette base c'est que le dialogue qui
a été noué avec l'ensemble des parties
prenantes
autant états unis d'amérique européen se
poursuivent pour bâtir au fond des
solutions de court et de moyen terme
avec quel objectif
la sécurité de tous il n'y a pas de
sécurité pour les européens s'il n'y a
pas de sécurité pour la russie en
lettonie et en estonie en lituanie en
pologne ou ailleurs ils ont les mêmes
craintes ils ont le sentiment aussi que
les mêmes accords avaient été violés
qu'on leur avait promis qu'il n'y aurait
pas de dépôt vente il ya eu des
déploiements donc il nous faut des
processus de transparence de désescalade
il nous faut rebâtir ses solutions
concrètes ensemble et donc les
prochaines semaines doivent être
consacré à cela et en même temps aussi à
notre capacité à bâtir cette sécurité en
respectant pleinement la souveraineté et
l'indépendance
de plusieurs états qui ne sont pas
membres de l'union européenne ou de
l'otan mais qui sont pour autant dans la
région pensent à la biélorussie je pense
à l'ukraine évidemment je pense à la
géorgie je pense à la moldavie qui sont
des états dont l'indépendance la
souveraineté doit être aussi pleinement
respectée car celle ci participe de
notre sécurité collective
alors tout ceci reste pour l'instant
assez abstrait mais le président
français a promis des mesures concrètes
rapidement après avoir consulté au
washington l'union européenne mais aussi
les pays les premiers concernés comme
l'ukraine dès aujourd'hui à l'occasion
d'une rencontre avec volodymyr et link
l'objectif de ces pourparlers dégager
des points de convergence qui pourront
satisfaire tout le monde une tâche ardue
pour laquelle les prochains jours et les
prochaines semaines seront décisifs
merci beaucoup antoine pour eux toutes
ces précisions antoine claireaux en
direct depuis moscou et cette rencontre
entre blaye